it's the number one reason I make
content I'm trying to get people to be
less scared so you lost me at least you
tried
anything
[Music]
we're in Amsterdam having that
okay
it's got
I'm clearly in a good mood I'm excited
bunch of leaders from our European
office so some of the folks from London
some of the folks from Amsterdam are
here and I'm excited to rock and roll
[Music]
I'm just gonna give everyone the preview
real quick which is enjoy your the
people you're close to because in about
15 minutes we're gonna be on one table
conversation collectively
it's the Only Rule then I'll ask you a
person question about them of course so
if you don't if you never felt fear
around the company and the journey when
did you feel the emotional fear as um as
Gary the human being not the CEO I
probably lived the ages of seven to
sixteen fearing that one of my parents
would die
four to six times a week
I think I got so much fear out of the
way as a kid that it impacted me you
know I didn't really understand it as I
got older I'm like oh I'm such an idiot
right my mom lost her mom at five my dad
lost his dad at 15. it was in the air I
thought it was very conceivable right
you know even if you notice the thing I
toast to it but somebody oh Dustin asked
me ask today yesterday whatever do I
have any superstitions and at first I
said no and I said wait a minute I do I
will not toast anything but good health
to Good Health
to me
the only thing I worry about is hell
because I can't control it everything
else I can live in a shoebox once you
have a relationship with humility
everything becomes amazing
you're not scared of anything
foreign
look I'm extremely happy to be here
looking forward to getting to know all
of you there's so much I can touch on I
would love to go into as much q a as
possible but like basically there's only
two things first second third and fourth
is how you feel when you come here if
you're upset on Sunday night and you're
pissed Monday morning we lost but you
need to be a contributor to fixing that
and then number two like you have to
learn the craft and I'm inspired to win
on both fronts with all of you and so
I'm very grateful I'm humbled you guys
have plenty of options of places you
could go work I want to take that
compliment of you considering to work
with us and build on it my biggest
frustration is I know how little I can
accomplish on both of those fronts in
this afternoon but my biggest hope is
that I can inspire you to act on the
things that will then allow us to
accomplish it and so I guess if you
leave with anything just call my bluff
it's funny you ask that historically the
answer to this question would still is
true is my parents the number one thing
I wish on people besides good health is
being born into a family that has
nothing when you learn in the first 10
years of your life that money has no
direct correlation to happiness life
becomes easy and that's what happened to
me I was so loved I was so happy we had
so little I'm like this is it what else
and so that's what keeps a lot of the
what may seem like [__] answers for
you that I'll prove to you are true it's
all grounded from that so they've always
been the answer to that question
however in my journey to like try to
find value or create perspective or
create debate or think something else
hit me recently that I've been talking
about a lot lately and because I take so
many 6 a.m flights I've had the luxury
of waking up at 4am quite a bit and
going to the airport at 4 30. something
hit me recently which is like oh there
is something else that really inspires
me which is when it is 4 50 in the
morning and you're going to the airport
and you look outside
and you see a 52 year old woman get out
of the subway four bags in her hand
maybe this woman is up doing this right
now because she just recently lost her
husband and she has three kids and she
has a regular nine to five but she's
taken on a six to nine a.m job just like
you know I paint these pictures for
myself these people that I see at four
and five in the morning who aren't Elon
Musk warrant Jeff Bezos who aren't Oprah
like these people are grinding often to
just put food on the plate for their
family maybe buy one luxury item for
their child they inspire me to no end
and then I go to another place in my
mind is and I bet you she doesn't even
complain the person I admire the most is
the people that have so much adversity
and not a peep not a [__] peep of
complaining about dumb [__] and so
the people that inspire me are the
people that nobody talks about that put
their family on their back
and [__] work to try to make it
better for their family
and have no capacity to complain about
it
maybe you can tell me first about the
network or for the media and where you
started the business over here and I
just you know in the Netherlands in
Amsterdam when I started the company 13
years ago it was on a mission to build a
Global Communications company I was
pretty agnostic on where we would go
after we started in New York first we
went to San Francisco we later moved
that to LA and then we went into London
and then Singapore you know we're going
to be everywhere Johannesburg and Cape
Town and Nigeria and the Middle East and
the Serendipity of clients and
governments and business realities will
sometimes dictate when and where yeah
and you know this one had a little bit
to do with needing to make sure we had
an office in Europe not just in London
and it being a place that I've been to a
lot of times and had a lot of fun in
this sport
to me the number one thing at this age
that you have to do is take risks early
on
because when you get older you regret
not taking risks please remember that if
anything from this forget about the
marketing strategies in your 20s is when
you take your biggest risks because when
you're 40 60 80. so you'll regret if you
don't you're going to be 77 and you're
gonna say why the [__] garyvee told me
20 50 years ago I should have listened
because it will kill you
much more than losing the biggest thing
that kids worry about is losing that's
why they don't take risks because they
don't want to lose in front of each
other in front of their parents it's the
number one reason I make content I'm
trying to get people to be less scared
so you lost me at least you tried
[Music]
to the homies
it's crazy
how a journalists I'll tell you exactly
that ready I want to write an article
about champagne that focuses on the fact
that Prosecco from Italy is now a good
alternative for a portion of the price I
want you to historically reference other
times in history when something was the
establishment and a product came along
that was equal of quality
but a fraction of the price and speak to
it in a manner that helps people
understand that quality of flavor is
subjective but price is not enter
so what is this the prompting I just
wrote a very good article for the London
Times about Prosecco and champagne
something will be outputted and then I'm
going to read it and I'm going to add 10
more sentences and edit six more
sentences so the creativity of the
writer and the ability of the editor
becomes a new form of a human being I
just literally talked out to you
[Music]
the genuine love for people I was
thinking about I was like what is it I'm
like you know there's just like I just
genuinely like in like a deep way like
even like walking by these windows like
I look at all those people and I'm like
yeah and like most people really don't
they're scared of people people hurt
them it's really crazy how like
perspective and like all that works
makes a big difference
because they're both equally true like
yes there's a lot of pain in the world
[Music]
but there's so much [__] like actual
love in the world yeah
just how you look at it
beautiful
the world man the world is beautiful if
you decide to look
incredibly humbled to see all of you a
bunch of faces I already know and a lot
of new faces that I know of but it's
great to put a face to some of the names
why don't I set up over there why don't
we line up if you want a selfie or to
sign something I'll bang through that
then I'll come right back here grab one
of these shares we'll hang out and do a
little q a and hang out
[Applause]
[Music]
the question really is around what are
your biggest challenges and how can we
help them assist you
it's very sweet you know giving without
expectation super easy for me being
vulnerable and asking for help
impossible you know I struggle with that
question you know the truth is God it's
really hard like I was so trained you
know as a first generation immigrant
where my mom's like you take care of
your sister at four so I'm like all
right I'm a [__] four-year-old and
I'm like I'm in work mode right my dad's
not around on my mom's partner in crime
I start working at 14. I become the
financial impact on my whole family at
18. I don't really have like the
capacity or like the training to
understand how to ask for help so you've
got all that framework here's the more
complicated part the truth is I'm
uncomfortably simple something that I
think would surprise you if you really
really knew me is how detached I am for
my own success I don't really get
validation
or affirmation from my career that's why
I called it be friends I like am more in
tune
with getting like validation from like
being a nice person and building friends
than I do of like making money or this
and that like where I'm getting caught
up is I'm not overly struggling with
anything it like the thing that makes me
the happiest is for you to be happy
honestly like listen to what I'm saying
in my content you want to make me happy
go act on the [__] that I'm talking
about because everybody here would be a
lot happier
thank you
[Music]
good night we put a lot of positivity
into the world today
[Music]